oh hello SE hello Aspen welcome to my
home thank you for having us what makes
this space feel like home besides my pet
cow pig uh Good Vibes good food
definitely good people good things all
around that's all you need now I want to
ask you a few questions about your
research you started your journey in HCI
and data visualization and then you
moved to ml and interpret tell me about
that yeah I think on the surface those
two Fields seem very different but they
both deal with this fundamental question
of data and how do we as people make
inferences on that data and make
decisions with that data so that's you
know the connection um I really wanted
to be a well-rounded researcher and I
loved the way that machine learning
researchers and theorists often
formalize evaluate and ask questions and
so yeah that's that's that's really what
got us here is well-roundedness okay
very interdisciplinary approach now I'm
getting a little distracted by that
record player and you have any favorites
I have so many um I listen to this
record a lot when I'm working it's
moonchild um it's got that R&B lowii
energy that I think is just very
conducive to work so priorities all
right I'll have to give that a listen
now back to your research one pillar is
data sets how significant is building
representative data sets in today's ml
landscape I think it's one of the most
important questions that we have is like
a lot of the problems that come from
bias um and issues of fairness in
machine learning tie back to having not
representative data sets so how can we
build those data sets that cover you
know the people the axes that we care
about so that the product or tool that
we build is is working the way we want
it to and what are some fundamental
challenges that you've run into doing
this type of work well anytime you're
trying to build something that is
representative it's very hard to figure
out what is not represented so I would
say that is the number one challenge all
right now I've heard of something called
out of distribution methods what are
they oh good question um out of
distribution methods are this kind of
like fueled in machine learning where
people ask okay well I know what is in
my training set um I know what my model
has learned now can I figure out what
the model is going to kind of do poorly
on that maybe is not within that
distribution so it's out of distribution
sometimes we call that anomaly detection
it depends on if you're working with
time series or you know a different data
type and how are you connecting that
with data
collection that is also a really good
question um so I think until maybe
recently we really had these topics very
separated um but it turns out if you
have a sense of the underlying
distribution of your data set um and you
take a partially trained model you can
use that model and those ad distribution
methods to Target direct and iterate
your data collection so that in the long
run you have a much more representative
data set okay I see a big pile of books
behind you as well sorry I keep getting
distracted any favorites here oh I've
got a lot
um let's go with these two uh whereas by
L long Soldier amazing amazing poet she
really knows how to work with sound I
love it and
objectivity got to have it got to love
it you know what time it is it's time to
go to
work speaking of that what's a typical
day like at se- sale you know what I'll
show you let's go on my way to work I
usually listen to audiobooks podcasts or
the occasional Spotify playlist what are
you listening to right now I'm listening
to ku's radio West it is a fantastic
Radio show/ podcast
okay sounds very popular for the East
Coast now another pillar of your
research fundamental ml work super
applicable right now can you explain the
debate on emergent World models um sure
uh large language models um have been
facing this really big question which is
are they just stochastic parrots so
memorizing surface statistics or are
they learning something a little bit
more meaningful about the world uh it's
an ongoing debate like you said so there
you go it's it's been summarized all
right so how do you you think looking at
really specific context is helping
explore this
question um that's a good question uh so
a couple months ago my co-authors and I
presented some work at I CLE we
basically found an emergent World model
uh in a large language model that was
trained from scratch on a fellow moov so
super super tightly constrained
environment and that model was
controllable and causal which is really
exciting um for the future of
interpretability and my my opinion but
it's also just the beginning of the work
so does that mean we're a little bit
closer to deploying safer AI uh we're
definitely not actively de deploying
safer uh ML and uh I would say that we
are also fully not finished with the
interpretability research landscape
although we're getting a lot closer okay
so then with the ubiquity of llms people
are starting to use them to generate
training data sets so what are some
challenges in using them for
that another fantastic question Rachel
um
I I have to say so you know one of the
nice things about large language models
is they're really good at producing
realistic outputs um but they're not so
good at producing realistic
distributions so any model that you
train on that resulting distribution may
have some problems look it's the
gnome I'm going to go to work because I
am now incredibly late from spending
time with you guys I'll see you at the
office
oh my gosh welcome to work oh well thank
you Aspen of course all right Aspen tell
me a little bit about your current work
the AI supply chain what is that that's
a another good question Rachel you're so
full of
them um so up until now all the AI
products that you might interact with
like chat Bots Alexa an AI radiology
assistant were largely built in-house
along one pipeline so data cleaning
development refinement evaluation
training Etc was kind of ordered and
organized by like one entity now it's a
little different the products that you
interact with are basically a bunch of
different things glued together whether
that's data sets models fine-tuned
models the world is changing and we're
thinking of this as a dispers learning
setting where you can have a lot of
different entities influencing the
downstream inferences okay and how does
dispersed learning impact the mitigation
of bias and fairness in AI that's a
really good question so when you have
you know more than
one entity contributing to a downstream
product um and by entity it could be an
organization it could be a person um but
you know you have kind of like this idea
of the downstream product doesn't have
control over up and the Upstream
products that are influencing it um as a
result it's really hard to tell if
something changes upstream and there's
now a failure here who's responsible and
this is a question of like liability and
accountability and it's one of the big
questions that we are trying to explore
with the disperse learning setting and
how could these challenges alter future
developments in ml yeah I mean that's a
really you know big problem um in
disperse learning in the AI supply chain
uh we're now trying to figure out how do
you deal with bias and fairness when
there are many actors that are playing a
role in learning um it's hard you can
have two perfectly Fair models and you
maybe combine them um through um voting
there's a lot of different ways to
combine models but um you can average
their weights for example and the result
you know has this weird sense of like
well who did what and now how do we know
what's wrong um so it challenges
stereotypical debugging strategies um
debiasing um strategies Etc okay big
open problem so I want to shift a little
bit how have all of your non-academic
experiences shaped your research and
policy interests oh my gosh uh well I
mean I think that's a really big
question and one that is hard to answer
uh I would say
I I'm just very passionate about making
people's lives better um and kind of
getting to the heart of Truth and there
are many ways to approach that from a
policy perspective and there are many
ways to approach that from a research
perspective okay now for all of this
work how do you balance the
interdisciplinary nature of projects
especially with Fields like sociology
and anthropology I think finding good
collaborators is an excellent way to do
that um also reading a lot
how did you stay on top of what's
happening in your research field I think
my lab is a really good resource uh and
academic Twitter although I guess it's
called X now um yeah talking to people
it's a good way to do it all right
moving on from the more technical stuff
you moved from Utah to Cambridge for MIT
that must have been quite the transition
big culture shock for sure all right so
did you venture outside of MIT for any
collaborations now that you've been here
you know what I did I got really lucky
with um collaborations at Harvard and
with people at Caltech and art center
and with people at Apple from doing
internships so very happy about those
experiences that's wonderful now
research can obviously be a long and
arduous process so talk to me about some
of the setbacks and what insights you've
gleaned from
that yeah I
mean research is an arduous process and
you often think something will work and
then it doesn't and then you try another
thing and it doesn't and
uh I think one of the biggest things
that you can develop as a researcher is
a sense of resiliency and stubbornness
um and a thick skin as someone once told
me and throughout that process have you
had any amazing mentorships or mentors
you know what I really I definitely have
um I think my current adviser Alexander
majer is an amazing Mentor I got really
lucky in undergrad with having amazing
women mentors that that were professors
that otherwise I probably would not have
even considered Academia an option so uh
yeah how has your approach to research
matured over time you get better at
asking good questions you have a better
sense of the existing literature of what
questions are interesting to the
research community and to yourself and
also how to start answering them so uh
maturity I
guess all right so are there any fun
might Traditions or hidden spots on
campus that Outsiders might not know
about um maybe the muddy it's a
pub uh for MIT Affiliates and it is
quite the space to hear the occasional
witty banter it's quite a scene is there
anything about MIT that you wish you
knew before you started
here yeah um you know what they say
about the hose being a water hose when
you come here uh it's definitely true um
you feel like you're drowning for a
little bit and then you get your feet
under you and you recalibrate and figure
out your people and takes a minute but
it's worth it I can only imagine so
after a long day's work then what helps
you
recharge
um yoga mindfulness sleeping all good
things oh hi hi asan I was wondering
through you Journey do you have any
piece of advice that is the most
impactful find people you like and work
with them although we haven't worked
together yet this isia she's
awesome all right we're going now byee
Aspen favorite CS resource the Internet
movie oh God this is going to be hard
happy as Lazaro all right favorite
restaurant in
Boston I didn't say this was going to be
easy ah um times out isn't a restaurant
but it's got a bunch of options and I
like it okay
artist um my mom class at MIT bills and
billions oh you're doing great aren't
you H this is pretty tough all right if
you're stranded on a desert island three
things you could take with you what's it
going to be ooh uh I guess a fishing
pole sunscreen and a desalinator is that
is that how you say that not what I
would choose but okay what's one thing
that recently inspired you besides you
oh you're too kind um
I'm taking a Harvard class called The
Art of listening and I think it's been
really inspirational it sounds
incredible all right Dream lab anyone
from history who's coming you know what
I don't know those people so I'll
probably stick to the people I'm working
with now because they're wonderful kind
and super smart favorite language to
program in Python all right if you could
have any piece of AI technology automate
something what would it be I want the
perfect laundr mat I would like that as
well let me know if you figure it out
okay if your research project was a dish
what would it be
Sushi I love raw fish all right if you
hadn't pursued a career in Academia in
research what other career path would
you have taken I mean this is still in
research but I loved dolphins and whales
when I was growing up and I really
wanted to be a theologist so probably
that okay so that was the dream as a kid
any other
dreams I mean besides being Mia ham for
those of you who know who she is
no okay based off of the pingpong skills
I think we we might have a little
difficulty there no I'm just kidding
just kidding okay I think you were the
problem it's possible so do you have any
hidden skills or talents that don't
involve ping pong or
soccer I have so many um they're hard to
count probably thrifting though everyone
asks for my advice you're hopping in a
time machine you're going back to any
time period just for a day where would
it be I don't want to go anywhere I
really like um
um it might sound a little wild but I
think that the kind of work that people
are doing and the kind of questions that
people are doing right now are really
important and also I don't want to be a
woman in most any other era so I will
second that what if you could go travel
into the
future can I travel like 200 years in
the future and just see where we're at
I'm hoping climate change is a problem
solved that would be a pipe dream now
what does artistic expression mean to
you it means mindfulness and being
grounded in your world and in your
feelings and in the experiences of
others now what has learning about
machines taught you about the way that
humans learn ooh uh a couple years ago I
read this really interesting paper about
numerosity which is you know how many
objects are in a particular image and
how we can recognize that and they used
a neural network to explore this
question and it had a lot of interesting
implications for how people understand
the count of OB objects all right A lot
of people are fearful of AI are you I
don't think I'm afraid of the same
things that people are afraid of in pop
culture at the moment um so yes and no
what are you most excited about for
AI I'm really excited about this like
growing potential for the applications
of machine learning and things that can
help people so kind of like a feminist
agenda you know um a friend of mine just
did a bunch of work in capturing and I
mean it's a little it's a little sad but
she did a lot of really interesting work
on capturing and highlighting these
instances of femicide and I think that's
incredibly important and it's hard to do
without algorithmic support absolutely
now in 5 years what do you want to be
working
on I hope I'm continuing work that I
feel strongly about and that has impact
um I
hope honestly I I really hope that I am
finding
collaborations that are you know also
interdisciplinary and that feel
motivating to me beautiful now what
advice would you offer to upcoming
researchers trying to get involved in
the
field find someone that you think is
exciting and interesting to talk to and
is in honestly doing interesting things
and literally just have a conversation
with them it's one of the best ways to
learn about a new space and it's also
one of the best ways to be inspired okay
last and final question we'll let you go
where does the name Aspen come from
um my mom likes trees oh I like trees
too all right thanks Aspen we'll see you
later